hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so what we're going to talk
about in this video is excuse me
verifying trig identities and we're
going through some different examples so
at the end of this video I'll have a
link to one of my other videos or a
couple of my other videos just talking
more about these same types of problems
so if you want more practice check those
out but let's get right into some of
these problems so cosine x times secant
x equals 1 so first of all let me just
kind of say that when you're verifying
trig identities the nice thing is is
that they give you the answer so we know
that this equals 1 we just have to show
step by step or verify or prove that the
left side equals the right side now what
you want to do when you're verifying
trig identities ideally is you just want
to work with one side of the equation
either the left side or the right side
and leave the other side alone and you
just want to do identical substitution
so identities mean meaning that they're
identical right but you can substitute
identical quantities and simplify it
until you can show that both sides are
equivalent so I'll show you what I mean
in these examples and you'll get a
better idea so this first one cosine of
X times secant of x equals 1 well we
know that secant of X is the reciprocal
of cosine of X ok so I'm just going to
do that identical substitution I'm just
substituting or swapping them out and
now I can see that these cosines are
going to cancel and I'm left with 1 over
1 which equals 1 so 1 equals 1 check
okay so we proved it that was an easy
one let's get into some more challenging
ones though let's take a look at this
one here secant squared X minus tangent
squared X over 1 minus cosine squared X
we're trying to show that equals
cosecant squared X now just a little
side note over here you probably
remember this Pythagorean trig identity
1 plus tangent squared equals secant
squared now you can rearrange that trig
identity by you know subtracting ok so
we're going to take secant squared we're
going to subtract tangent squared and if
we move that to the side you can see you
can see that secant squared minus
tangent squared equals 1 right so this
numerator is equal to 1 and then the
same thing with this tonight
or if you remember the Pythagorean trig
identity sine squared plus cosine
squared equals one that's the basic
Pythagorean trig identity one minus
cosine squared if I subtract cosine
squared from both sides you can see that
that's going to equal sine squared so
I'm going to replace that with sine
squared X and we know that the
reciprocal of sine is cosecant but since
this is squared this is going to be
equal to cosecant squared X and so there
you go you've proved it okay let's go on
to another example sorry with me so far
you just want to keep doing those
substitutions notice I'm working with a
more expanded side the larger side
usually it's the left side and I'm
trying to condense it down until that I
can show step by step that equals the
right side so let's take a look at this
example now tangent of X I know is what
its sine over cosine right so sine x
over cosine X and then over here we have
cosine x over one okay and so I'm just
gonna simplify down a little bit more
this is sine squared X over cosine X
okay but now over here I just have
cosine x over one right now I can see
from the right side that this is just
like one term it's just one quantity
over here I have two quantities
separated by the addition sign I want to
combine those together or condense it
into one term so the obvious thing I
think to do here would be to get the
common denominators and I'm going to do
that by multiplying the numerator and
denominator by cosine of X so if we do
that
we're gonna get cosine squared X over
cosine X plus sine squared X over cosine
X but since they have the same
denominator I'm just gonna combine them
into one fraction okay sian squared plus
cosine squared we talked about is 1 so
this is going to be 1 over cosine X
which equals secant X and we proved it
so let's take a look at another example
now one thing I want to mention is you
know as you're doing these you're gonna
want to memorize some of the basic
Pythagorean trig identities and some of
the basic identities because you're
gonna be using them all the time and if
the more that you know them and memorize
them the more they're gonna jump off the
page at you but let's go ahead and take
a look at this one here so this one is a
little bit more
we've got a sign of a negative angle
sign of a negative angles the same as
the opposite of sign of the positive
angle okay and you can see these two
negatives are gonna cancel so that
becomes one plus sine of X numerator is
still cosine of X now what I'm going to
do here might not be so obvious at first
glance but I'm going to multiply by the
conjugate of the denominator so instead
of one plus sine of X I'm going to
multiply it by one minus sine of X I'm
going to foil this out so the
denominator is one minus sine squared of
X okay because you can see the inside
and outside are going to cancel and
you're gonna get one and then negative
sine squared of X and the numerator I'm
just going to leave as cosine x times
one minus sine X okay so I'm not going
to distribute that one minus sine
squared X again here comes that
Pythagorean trig identity again 1 minus
sine squared of X I'm subtracting sine
squared from both sides that equals
cosine squared
okay cosine squared so we have cosine X
over one minus sine x over cosine
squared X one of these cosines cancels
with one of these and now you can see we
have 1 minus sine x over cosine X I'm
going to split this up into two
fractions 1 over cosine X minus sine
over cosine X and you know that 1 over
cosine are the reciprocal of cosine is
secant so there's our secant X and sine
over cosine is tangent X so we proved it
now I didn't mention this earlier but
what you want to do because it's an
identity you already know the answer so
you want to keep your eye on you the
right side or the left side of the
equation because you know where you want
to take this so you can kind of you know
garner some hints from looking at that
other side of the equation and kind of
steer your decisions about what types of
substitutions you might want to do
sometimes when you're doing this there
can be a lot of steps and you might feel
that maybe you you know run yourself
into a corner and you get stuck just go
ahead and back up a few steps try some
different substitutions and try taking
the problem a slightly different way as
long as you keep substituting equivalent
quantities you know it might just take
you a few extra steps you'll still get
to where you want to go it just might
take a little bit longer let's look at
this last example
and then we'll wrap up this video this
one here we haven't talked about yet
these are the co functions cosine of 90
minus X or PI over 2 minus X this is
equal to the sine of X okay so cosine
and sine are Co functions tangent and
cotangent secant and cosecant so this is
equivalent to sine of X cotangent of X
is equal to cosine over sine and you can
see that the signs are going to cancel
and so we have cosine ax equals cosine X
and we proved it so I hope this video
helps you understand how to work with
verifying trig identities a little bit
better check out the other videos that
I'll have links to about some of the
other videos I did regarding the same
topic and subscribe to the channel I
look forward to seeing the future videos
and I look forward to helping you with
your math so I'll talk to you soon